bon les gars là
[Musique]
car mission oui comme d'habitude
comment vous l'imaginez la fille avec
qui vient même si la première fois nous
présente une fille depuis son divorce
n'avait pas tout de suite a payé tout
seul gastro de cuisine et si on faisait
un jeu un jeu
on pourrait par exemple poser tous notre
téléphone sur la table et tout ce qui
arrive ce soir on regarde tous ensemble
et on lit tout à voix haute
on va ce serait drôle non drôle
d'annoncé je crois pas steckly vas-y à
leur montre mais si je te mangerais bien
qui comment je tiens à les oiseaux
[Musique]
trivial pursuit on a failli se battre
vincent ramassage
[Musique]
il ya 30 % chez jardiland et je peux pas
y aller faut que tu m'aides j'ai une
amie qui m'en vois tous les soirs une
photo d'elle non sourire ça va pas faire
ta femme justement échanges jetant de
recevoir la photo et c'est moi qui passe
pour un con je peux le cas c'est comme
ça
nous montre cadence avec une gastro tu
peux pas tu veux pas faire ça encore
juste un numéro j'y vais même pas
enregistrer c'est une erreur
[Musique]
10 heures enfin les c'est amusant ça a
l'air tendu autour de 1 s'est passé un
truc perdant le mariage
vous imaginez le nom de divorce si
chacun fouille et d'un porte à de l'eau
a reçu un message facebook
quelqu'un qui veut savoir si tu prends
ton pilote pour arrêter que ce jeune
arrêté
[Musique]